es gibt keine epidemiologische lage von
nationalem ausmaß wie das hier irgendwie
zum dritten mal behauptet wird das ist
keine pandemie in irgendeiner weise das
geben auch die wirklich relevanten
kriterien her und das sind die in den
krankenhäuser liegen wenn schwer kranken
sowie natürlich die sterben denn an
corona und über 300 ja intensivpatienten
das ist nichts für so was bei dieser
unglaublichen zahl von infizierten
wahrscheinlich ist sogar noch eine
höhere zahl was im prinzip sogar eine
gute nachricht wäre denn so läuft jede
virusinfektion sich irgendwann zu tun
indem es einfach immer mehr leute
bekommen
praktisch nicht merken in fast allen
fällen so liegt das immer so wird es
immer laufen wo waren all die ganzen
moralapostel bei den grippewellen die
viel viel schlimmer waren mit viel viel
mehr toten der letzten jahre und
jahrzehnte sie waren einfach nicht da
niemand auf die idee gekommen einen lock
down zu verfügen zu diesem wegen diesen
geschichten das ist alles völlig neu das
ist eine pervertierung des geistes des
infektionsschutzgesetzes deswegen gibt
es auch darüber rede ich heute aber
nicht auch eine klage der afg fraktion
es werden sehr wahrscheinlich dass
apparaten pressekonferenz noch mal
vorgestellt bekommen gegen den neu
gefassten infektion paragraf 5 des
infektionsschutzgesetzes der erst im
märz neu gefasst wurde und in dem der
begriff der epidemischen lage nationalen
ausmaß überhaupt erst erfunden wurde und
zwar kriterien frei das ist der
entscheidende vorwurf sowohl der
gesundheitsminister als auch der
bundestag als ganzes als auch der
bundestagspräsident hier im haus können
ohne jedes kriterium
die epidemische lage oder irgendwelche
notlagen behaupten und auch wieder
beenden
niemand kann das jemals überprüfen
deshalb ist der neu gefasst 'die § 5 das
hauptübel und damit jetzt erst der
schwenk zum haushalt denn der haushalt
aktuell mit 96 milliarden
neuverschuldung in dieser 21er variante
insgesamt also 315 milliarden corona
schuld den letzten sechs monaten 315
jahr sind ist nur möglich weil eine
satirische note situation begründet auf
einer gesundheitlichen notsituation
basierend
behauptet wird und diese notsituation
hat aber voraussetzungen die
voraussetzung ist eine davon die
wichtigste dass diese notlage der
kontrolle des staates entzogen ist und
aufbauen auf dem was ich eben gesagt
habe war es eben nicht mehr so dass
jetzt zum dritten mal praktisch ohne
tote es gibt heute zum beispiel habe ich
gerade gelesen fünf tote
kroner sind gestern gemeldet wurden fünf
jahre und wir wissen inzwischen dass nur
einer davon
rein statistisch wirklich kausal an und
nur an corona gestorben sein wird das
ist einer das ist keine pandemien das
ist die aktuelle lage
dem steht gegenüber die völlig
hysterisch reaktion der regierung haben
wir morgen oder heute oder übermorgen
ein neues treffen der kanzlerin mit den
länderchefs bei den noch schärfere
maßnahmen verkündet werden soll mit
verheerenden konsequenzen für die ganze
wirtschaft und natürlich auch für den
haushalt also biss erhalten dass wir dem
grunde nach unzulässig jetzt die
notsituation nachfolger von artikel 115
2 6 grundgesetz aussuchen ohne das
dürfte aber olaf scholz diese menge an
schulden überhaupt nicht machen
die zweite kritik auch rechtliche kritik
die wir haben ist das ein großteil der
mittel die jetzt natürlich frei gemacht
werden mit dieser verschuldung gar nicht
kausal für und auf corona folgen
verwendet werden ein teil schon aber bei
weitem nicht alles das es auch
unzulässig und wir sehen natürlich schon
dass gewisse dinge nun gebracht werden
müssen aufgrund der vorangegangen den
fehl entscheidungen gibt es derzeit in
diesem land fast zehn millionen
kurzarbeiter
es wird auch nicht besser es wird auch
potenziell eine massenarbeitslosigkeit
geben nächstes jahr das ist alles sicher
aufgrund der maßnahmen erst recht wenn
sie jetzt noch mal verlängert und
natürlich braucht man dann geld die
bundesanstalt für arbeit braucht mehr
geld für diese kurzarbeitergeld das ist
sicher die 3 milliarden die olaf scholz
dafür eingestellt hat wird werden nie
und nimmer erreichen in 2021 das ist
also schon ein riesen problem hier und
wir glauben dass diese gelder bereits da
sind in form von resten aus haushalten
in form von der auflösung der also wirkt
jeweiligen asyl rücklage die eben nicht
angetastet wird
ebensowenig viele ideologische rücklagen
aus dem energie und klimafonds
die in summe locker die 70 milliarden
bringen die ungefähr olaf scholz zu viel
schulden aufnimmt